- app it is fastest easiest way to send
money you get a personalized debit card
with great rewards and you can buy a
Bitcoin so we launched the Play Store in
2013 and as of December we had 15
million active users in 2015 one of my
co-workers are at this document using
Project Koplin in Android and it got us
were all really excited about it ever
since Android studio and the Android
team have embraced Collin thinks have
gotten even better whenever we want to
change a new feature we always convert
it to Collin first one of the things I
really liked about Colin is lambdas it
really makes programming with our ex
Java very easy and fluent and it was
something that allowed us to take two
different technologies that we really
liked any of them together with Collin
we're able to eliminate many builders
and we're able to really cut down on the
amount of code we write in some cases we
save 25% of our code I really like
Collins fantastic deprecation features
it allows us to evolve our API as our
business problems change and quickly
update all the call sites we're
constantly improving our business model
and solving more problems and with that
we need to migrate new code to the
latest model replace with it makes that
very fascinating one of the features
were really excited about is Collin
multi-platform it's gonna give our
Android developers the ability to ship
code on iOS and our iOS developers the
ability should put on Android with
sealed classes we can create loading
error and content screens all in a
single sealed type and this allows us to
move faster to make changes and really
understand our data model in a stronger
type safe way I - we shipped the app
every two weeks with Collin we're able
to get more code with higher quality in
every release I think it's time to dive
in I think Collin is ready I think that
when you use it you'll see just how much
it transforms how you think about your
code
you